all right what's up it's Sean and I'm
going to start by reading you a tweet
that I did a year ago it says I have a
new hero and her name is Sarah Moore and
the reason that Sarah Moore is my hero
and somebody that you probably never
heard of is because Sarah Moore was
somebody who was a student in college
that you know she's in her young 20s she
has no money no experience uh the only
thing she owned in her life was her car
a Rav 4 and she hustled this crazy
hustle story of how she basically
decided I'm gonna buy a business even
though I got nothing nothing to my name
and she spends a year searching through
100,000 businesses and she finds this
Niche business called eggcartons.com uh
you literally this guy sells the carton
that your eggs come in and she bought
this million you know multi-million
dollar business with all debt um so she
put no money in because she didn't have
any money and so and then she had grown
it a bunch since then and I just said I
think this is like a $2 million business
that this woman bought and like wow what
a hustler so I told this hustle story on
the podcast and it kind of went viral it
blew up nobody had ever heard about this
story before she has done no interviews
she has no social media she was like a
ghost and I honestly I didn't even know
if it was true because it's one of these
stories that's too good to be true uh
here's this girl who comes from
absolutely nothing she talks about this
in the interview like she literally had
no parents she was in and out of jail as
a kid like she was just trouble and then
she has this turning point in her life
that gave me goosebumps she ends up
paying somebody to take the SAT so she
gets into college she hustles her way
through college uh finds a way to buy
this business and it's this amazing
success story and two things happened
one the story kind of went viral she
said that like Netflix and others
reached out to her after the episode
went live that people started showing up
on her doorstep asking them asking her
for advice on buying a business and like
honestly it was kind of bad like it was
too much and please don't do that again
because she's like dude I'm trying to
run a business I don't even know you you
start telling my story and this went
crazy and so a year later now she's like
okay first I was kind of like wow this
is crazy then I was kind of annoyed and
scared like is this going to mess up my
business but then as she started to see
you know the upside of telling her story
and she was like look I still have no
social media I still do no interviews
but you kind of you were very nice and
you told my story I will agree to come
on and do one interview and so she's
like after this I'm one and done I'm
going to come on and I'm going to lay it
all out there I will tell you everything
you want to know about buying a business
how I did it what I did the good and the
bad all the mistakes that I made uh I'll
tell my kind of the life story part two
that's the sort of you know made for TV
it's it's unbelievable her life story
along the way and she's like I'm doing
one interview and then that's it I'm
disappearing after that and she did not
disappoint we just finished the
recording uh it's one of my favorite
episodes we've ever done she is somebody
that I really admire and I don't use
that term lightly like she is really a
hustler super genuine and her story is
um is frankly incredible like it's not
often I have gooseb bumps during an
episode of a podcast so enjoy this
episode with Sarah
[Music]
Mo all right today's episode is going to
be all about buying a business rather
than starting a business we usually talk
about ideas that you should use to start
a business but as you know like U one of
our best uh friends of the house Andrew
Wilkinson has told us many times buying
a business can be a better path but uh
how the hell do you actually do it that
is the question and we're going to talk
to somebody who not only has done it not
only has done it successfully but has
really never told her story you Sarah
Moore you are basically not on the
internet welcome to the internet because
I first heard your story and then I went
Googling and I couldn't find anything
you were a ghost uh intentional or
unintentional very intentional I'm a
very private person and I'm not a fan of
public attention
you kind of blew up my spot though so
things have changed a bit yeah sorry
about that so we a long time ago I don't
know what it was hundreds of episodes
ago um I came on the Pod and I said hey
I got a story for you I said I would
love to have this person on as a guest
but you can't find them on the internet
I said I think this is kind of an
incredible story there's this woman who
out of college um bought a most boring
sounding business you could think of
eggcartons.com and I called you like the
queen of queen of carton or something
like that and I was like she's the the
queen of eggs and she buys this business
that some guy had been running for like
20 years and um she's running it she's
growing it and I was like the way she
did it with no money down I was like her
story sounds really interesting but
again there's literally one like text
interview of you on the whole internet
so then I I did I emailed you and I said
hey I'd love to have you come on I don't
think I got a reply or something but
then I sent you a Google doc and I said
look I just have to know I got to I need
answers to these questions just from my
own personal curiosity I sent you a
Google do I said just can you just fill
this out and to my surprise you actually
did and so when I came on the Pod and I
told your story suddenly a bunch of
people were were very interested in you
giving you a lot of attention and uh
correct me if I'm wrong sometimes in not
the most nice nice way it wasn't all
good is that right that's correct I've
I've come across quite the cast of
characters and why do you uh what do you
think what do they say to you where
where how are they finding you and what
do they say to you some people beg me to
talk to them for 15 minutes they'll
offer someone specifically offered me
$500 for five minutes of my time and
it's crazy because I'm so irrelevant
most days I'm out in s in Massachusetts
so there's not much happening here I'm
kind of under the radar so all of a
sudden I've now gotten a ton of
inquiries from people and a lot of
people want specific information a lot
of people are emailing to say hey I'm
doing this exact thing how do you get
financing or can I get your opinion on
this business deal or I'm about to close
how did you get a bank to actually do
your deal without putting much or any
money down right right well hopefully uh
hopefully this podcast tells your story
in a good way does not create even more
uh people chasing you down because we're
just going to tell all the answers right
here so that people everybody leave
Sarah alone after this yes I'm serious
please do not contact my business you
can email me or or really reach out to
me on LinkedIn but please do not contact
my business or show up there for that
matter yeah yeah we've had a couple of
those a few
stragglers there's always a few
stragglers unfortunately there's always
a few stragglers uh it doesn't help that
your story is kind of unique because you
didn't come from money um and we're
going to talk about that you didn't know
how to do this it's not like you knew
how to do this or you were an expert you
were a total beginner when you started
so that's appealing um your woman doing
this I think that's more unique uh so
there's like there's a whole bunch of
like angles and then you did it in a
kind of a niche that sounds kind of like
you know like boring businesses have
become sexy now and so you did it in a
boring business and so I think there's a
bunch of reasons people are excited but
let's let's start at the start so okay
let's just start with the high level
what did you actually do you uh were in
school and you decided I want to buy a
business first tell us why did you
decide that how did you even know that
that was a path you could go down oh boy
there's a lot of context here so But to
answer your question in the simplest of
of ways is I was between my first and
second year business school and I was
talking to somebody about what they
wanted to do afterwards and they
mentioned something called a search fund
which is where you essentially can go
out and buy some grungy business and
become the CEO basically overnight
without any money or experience that was
very appealing to me you're like hey I
fit that criteria no money no experience
absolutely buiness is sign me
up our software is the worst have you
heard of HubSpot see most crms are a
cobble together mess but HubSpot is easy
to adopt and actually looks gorgeous I
think I love our new CRM our software is
the best HubSpot grow better and so you
hear this idea and you're like what was
your plan before that were you did you
have another plan or like did this
replace something or you just put it in
in a vacant spot
so okay we'll do a bit of Storytelling
here yeah please when when I was in
business school there was a guy I was
working on a project with and he was
incredibly responsive almost annoyingly
responsive kind of one of those and I
asked how are you so responsive all the
time and he said Goldman and he's
referring to Goldman Sachs and he said
at Goldman saxs there was a rule of 15
minutes meaning you had to respond to
whatever form they reached out to you in
within 15 minutes 24 hours a day 7 days
a week and I said okay so what if you're
in the shower 15 minutes right what if
you're running a marathon 15 minutes
Christmas day 15 minutes and my favorite
what if your wife is giving birth 15
[__] minutes and I mean we laugh
but my I worked my ass off to get into
business to even graduate high school
worked my ass off to be frank and I'm
thinking you went to an Ivy League
undergrad you're clearly off the chart
intelligent you have this amazing
network of people you come from money
you have everything that I
don't why would you choose to
essentially sign up to be frank someone
else's [__] like I didn't say that to
him but that was my thinking and so I
had no idea what I wanted to do but up
until then I was at HBS Harvard business
school trying to fit in with all of
these people and sort of find my footing
and after that I'm thinking I don't want
to be like these people I don't want to
do this I don't want to be a consultant
I don't want to be a banker this is so
not me and if I'm going to be someone
else's [__] like that's just not an
option for me right I'm only going to be
one person's [__] and that's my own
yeah that's every entrepreneur ever
there was a guy who um there's a guy who
we went to college with he was our next
door neighbor in our dorm great guy Sam
soy and he went to work at UH same thing
Goldman or one of these one of these
Banks I don't even know what the hell
that was that's just foreign world to me
I don't know Sam's gone and he doesn't
you know he's busy now he works 80 hours
a week and he uh he read our blog we
used to blog about how we were building
our company and we'd be like yeah we
woke up we did the we had these calls
and we were pitching this guy and then
we went for a hike because we lived in
Boulder it's like we went for a hike in
the middle of the day because that was
awesome then we had an idea on the hike
and we came back and did it it sounded
so sexy in reality it was honestly
pretty lame but you know it was like
blogging was like social media it's like
Instagram back then you make it look
good and so Sam quits his job and he
moves into our our bedroom or moves into
our our living room lives on our couch
and he's like I'm goingon to do this I'm
like dude you were making six figures
you're making zero figures here and he's
like um and he he's like yeah but it's
better we couldn't really understand the
culture and then he sent an email and we
were like hey Sam you said something in
this email I've never heard before but
you said hey can you get that to me ASAP
or sooner and I was like what do you
mean ASAP or sooner ASAP means as soon
as possible and he's like a that's a
banking thing it's ASAP or sooner I'm
like what the [__] is sooner than ASAP
and I was like that's the mentality I
was like I get it I get why you quit I
get while you're out of there because
asaper sooner is not a way to live not
at all and it honestly blows my mind
again given the pedigree of these people
you would think you would shoot for the
moon year you would want to have this
freedom in your life but you're
literally choosing a form of enslavement
enslavement in my opinion right right
right yeah anytime you know I think
banking Consulting these are often brain
drains the talent really talented people
go there because it's sort of uh safe um
and it's like a well respected path but
if you think about how much how many
more cool interesting things could be
built or created if those same talented
people went out and and and did more
entrepreneurship but you know whatever
to each their own so you hear that
you're like all right I'm not going to
do that and now you you hear this idea
of buying a business okay but where do
you start how do you even know how to
start and we're going to go into your
fullback story but like the kind of the
high school how you even got to college
which is a crazy story in itself we're
going to get to there but first you hear
this idea about buying a business okay
Sarah now what what do you do great
question so I to your point in the
beginning I lacked the ability to
evaluate businesses I had no experience
doing that prior to business school I
was in the steel industry and I thought
if I could get a business I was pretty
comfortable with the idea that I could
run it probably if I tried hard enough
but searching in itself I thought I need
to have background in private Equity I
have no idea what I'm doing and people
will say you have a Harvard MBA but
Harvard is very corporate they don't
teach you how to look at a corporate or
commercial window washing business and
evaluate their financials to see if you
want to buy it right they're looking at
very complicated Financial models which
these are not at all and so I thought I
probably need to go the investor route
because there are investors out there
that will actually pay you to search I'm
thinking that's incredible someone's
going to pay me to look for this and
then they're going to invest this is
amazing look further into it and see
that if you were to get an investor to
back you they'll give you plenty of
money you can live a cushy life you can
do this in a fancy office you can whine
and dine these sellers but you have to
pay back one and and a half times that
and so if they gave me to 50% increase
so if they had given me 200k to search
I'd have to pay back 300K so that in and
of itself was absolutely
ridiculous and so one of my friends
actually sat me down and convinced me
that if you it's similar to dating he
said and if you get enough reps in you
cannot not recognize a good business
when you see
one for whatever reason I figure I may
as well just try and go out my own worst
case scenario literally worst case I
bring someone in Midway but why not at
least give it a go on my own and see
what happens right so what so what did
you do you you decide to go on your own
um how do you go about it what was your
process okay so step one for me I'm not
good with technology and I didn't have
any money so Step One is I'm going to
Leverage What I've got around me which
is I'm now in a school with a bunch of
smart people so I had one of my smart
friends scrape one of the databases with
all the private companies within an hour
and a half of my apartment in Boston
that's step one yeah you're like you're
like my criteria is it's an hour and a
half away tell me every private business
in this area truly and the problem is
with these databases people think oh
you've got all this great information
not really the we estimated just by
looking at some financials we actually
knew about that the database was
accurate about 50% of the time accurate
meaning the owner's name is correct the
revenues correct the employee count all
of those metrics because they're all
self-reported right so who's actually
going to give you accurate information
knowing it could be public right and so
we tried to pair down the list by
Revenue but we did it by multiple of
like 5x meaning let's say a business so
for instance the business I'd worked for
previously it said that business did a
million dollar in Revenue the business
is doing over $100 million in Revenue
right it there's all this information
but we tried to narrow it down somewhat
anything over I think a 100,000 or I'm
sorry $100 million we took off the
list uh Revenue wise it was fair game
yeah after that it was obvious things
and when I say obvious I mean it you
have to be sure so that would be a legal
firm or an accounting firm or 7-Eleven
other than that again fair game because
my business was actually under farming
so everything else you don't know it's
it's self- selected the industry we kept
the rest there so we were still up with
a pretty massive list of companies and
you told me by the way you said one of
your things is like you think industry
is overrated you think people over index
on I'm looking in this space this is the
niche this is the industry I'm looking
in you don't believe in that and you
didn't do that uh why do you think
that's the case so initially here's why
I I think that from experience initially
I did what I think most people do what
investors actually require you to to do
you sit there and you have a thesis
about the kind of industries that would
be great businesses and usually those
Industries have characteristics that
make them stable which is what you're
looking for when you're buying a
business with a lot of debt and what I
found is that the industries were
absolutely irrelevant what matters is
that you find a business that is
established and has been consistently
profitable for a number of years
everything else garbage there are so
many businesses in amazing Industries
like let's talk Pest Control right great
industry you've got people that have
pested they're not going to say you know
what not a great year for me this year
I'm just going to let my house be
infested like that's not really a thing
right it almost gives you I think
Industries a false sense of security
because you think just cuz I'm in this
Pest Control business I'm good when
you're really not there's way more to it
than that and so what I found is find a
business that's established and
consistently profitable for get the
industry cuz people could say I'm in
e-commerce right so that's that's a
that's an unstable industry I worked in
the steel industry you would think
that's an absolute hell no business I
used to work for it's a hell yeah it's
great great business right but
Industries would tell you otherwise
gotcha so you didn't look top down at
industry instead you were just like okay
I have this you have this list you
remove the obvious outliers businesses
that are way too big for you to buy and
now you have still an enormous list and
here you are one person sitting on
campus trying to sort through this um so
what was your approach what' you do well
I wasn't a oneman show here thank God or
I wouldn't have made it I hired hella
interns and I didn't mean for it to get
as big as it did but initially I had
five interns that worked for me and we
actually did the industry approach we
did the painstaking process of look each
interned to give me 50 companies a week
with they were they met my criteria
these company
you found email addresses for and then
we contacted there were five you had
five interns but you're a college
student you're an intern what how did
you get how does an intern have interns
what what what happened here so I'm
quite the pitch and truthfully here's
what it is and I swear to you like I use
what I learn searching every single day
and my interns tell me this all the time
we text each other about it all the time
private Equity this is private equity
and private Equity is an industry where
they don't do free internships you're
more of a liability waste of their time
than the free internship so you're not
going to get a free internship at a
private Equity Firm you need to have
actual skills you need to have
Investment Banking skills probably
before you're even at their front door
and so this opportunity is hey you're
going to get private Equity experience
and I'm going to give you transparency
into everything I'm huge on transparency
so I created a conference line and I
said I'm going to let every single
person listen on these calls whenever
they want so those were calls with all
the owners Brokers accountants attorneys
anyone from HBS anyone that I contacted
my phone was basically tapped 247 if
you're interested in finance this is
very helpful actually I mean who
wouldn't want to it's like you Sean sure
people would would is weirdly enough
want to listen in on your calls when
you're talking business when you're
doing business deals you would learn a
lot I'm sure so that's a huge portion of
it the learning Ben Graham told Warren
Buffett Warren Buffett was he admired
Benjamin Graham and he wanted to go work
for him and he said I'll work for you
for Warren Buffett says I'll work for
you for free and Ben Graham goes your
price is too high and um because it
you're right it's the time the energy so
for for for a lot of people they're not
even they're going to say no to a free
uh for to somebody who's willing to work
for free because the time and energy it
takes to train somebody and give them
that access is too expensive um relative
to the free labor but you smart you made
it a different you were in the opposite
position you're like I do need help I do
need free labor and um you rebranded
yourself as private equity which
technically you were but absolutely
private equity for sure it's like
where's your office it's like it's in
the cafeteria we sit at this table and
that's my office um all right so works
and these were other Harvard students or
these are just people in the in the area
No in fact I initially used the student
job boards and they were actually the
worst you get these cookie cutter
students who think like everybody else
they were basic the best interns I found
came off Craigslist my one of my first
interns who was with that initial batch
of five he was with me from the entire
duration of my search and he came off of
Craigslist nice it's people that aren't
just thinking like every other college
student and by the way a lot of these
weren't college students you told me
something you were like you know
initially we're going through this list
of like 400,000 businesses that like you
know were in the criteria and so even if
you're doing 50 outreaches a day and we
have
5 10 15 interns doing this the math
ain't math it just doesn't work you
can't get through this list so you Chang
your approach what did you do absolutely
so we realized our response rate is
awful I no matter how customized you get
you're reaching out to people most of
which aren't looking to sell their
business so it's a very low response
rate so if it's already this bad we may
as well just start and we're already
filtering in the wrong way we made many
mistakes the interns would have all
these false positives false negatives we
decide we're just going to light
everybody and their mother up because if
you look at email addresses they're all
more or less the same you start to see a
pattern if you're looking all day for an
email address you see most emails are
first name last initial at domain first
initial last name at this it's the same
for patterns so we created a big Excel
file guessed the combinations and then
ran them through something I think it
was bulk email checker to see whether or
not they were actually like real
addresses and so you you get their
contact info and now you're going to
email all of them one generic email
because you're like [__] it my response
R is bad anyways um if even if it gets
cut in half but I can email five times
more or 10 times more people oh yeah
that's a good
trade absolutely and what was
interesting is you know we we had this
huge list of people and we You' think oh
well if somebody reaches back out to me
how am I going to talk to them but you
realize it's kind of the same
conversations over and over so we would
do this approach where it's like bombs
away and I after we'd send out an email
we'd be getting tons of phone calls from
people and we had sent the emails out in
such a way that it looked like it was
done targeted like it looked like we
specifically did our research it said
hey I I'm looking for a business to buy
and yours seems to perfectly fit the
bill because it's within this Revenue a
new Range it's been around for a really
long time and it's been profitable for a
number of years and the people that
reached that responded and said actually
no you idiot that's not true great now
we know that perfect right yeah they
filled out your survey essentially yeah
they didn't but they didn't realize it
they thought they were telling us off
yeah and the best replies were the ones
that were wow you really did your
research here this is great they reach
out to me they're telling me how much
research I've done I have no idea who
they are I've got the intern scrambling
figuring out what area code is this who
is this what could this possibly be as
I'm pretending to have spent this time
researching their business I have no
clue right it's like being at a party
and then somebody knows you but you
don't remember where they're at so you
have to say really generic things to uh
to keep the keep it going while your
brain is like searching searching like
how do I know this person what is their
name exactly exactly and so you uh what
was your specific criteria did you have
like a revenue Target or did you have
like a e the Target that you were using
initially I looked at businesses ideally
between 4 million and 20 million in
revenue and I wanted something at or
above a million and a half in I okay but
over time that changed again just like
the industries you realize why does it
need to be this way I realized so much
of what I was doing was just based off
of what I had heard over and over and so
things got tweaked as I realized I
didn't need to necessarily have that
criteria I actually lowered my expect
ations a lot and standards it worked out
well I think and so you uh you lower you
you widen your thing you're reach out to
a bunch of people and one and one of
them is this business uh EDG cartons uh
that eggcartons.com so what stood out
there and then tell the story about how
you ended up buying that company okay so
I send out that email which again looks
like it's customized but it's not the
owner sends back a very long email
saying wow you really done your research
I am so impressed and he starts
outlining the specifics of what I said
in the email you're right we have been
around for a while we started in 2001
and this business has been to your point
profitable ever since consistently we
have an amazing reputation we have a
very strong customer base and from there
I said okay this has my interest because
at first let me back up I'm getting this
email and I'm thinking guys we're
reaching out to Farms now because it
looked like they were a farm
Feed Store it really did and so I the
first thing I always wanted to know was
okay let's see the financials because if
the numbers aren't there numbers meaning
you have actually been as you allege
consistently profitable for a number of
years I'm not really interested right
but they were there and so anytime you
see that you know because it is a rare
by the way I would say maybe 5% of the
businesses we looked at were
consistently profitable and established
that few and so he had he met those
parameters I'm immediately interested
and so I started asking about the
business and learning a little bit more
like okay this is a commodity right and
he says no it's not we actually have a
lot of proprietary products we have some
patents I don't sorry just explain
explain what it is it's literally the
carton that your eggs come in you you
buy a dozen eggs they have to be
packaged in something yes this guy was
making the packaging he was
manufacturing it or he was the middleman
he was the middleman yeah I'll back up
so I found out what they're basically
doing is they're a Wholesale Distributor
and they're buying storing and selling
egg currents so I immediately think okay
this is simple enough that an a person
with average intelligence me can do this
like I think I could sell an egg card I
think I could buy one
too that was essentially what it was the
business of course though again there
were proprietary products there were a
couple things that made it much more
desirable but at the end of the day
we're buying and selling eight cartons
right right and the website I went to it
now which is like you know after you
took over and it's so basic uh and we've
talked about this on the thing the logo
isn't even just the logo it's egg
cards.com so you you have the Doom in
the logo which is great and then under
it attached to that in the same image is
your 1 1800 number it's like you know
call 188 uh 825 what whatever whatever
and so this business is so simple and so
old school looking but you weren't
scared Away by that you actually you
wanted that you didn't want some
internet business you didn't want
something that was like kind of new and
Innovative is that right that's correct
I think you have to play to your
strengths here this is where you it's
not so General you you can buy a
business that suits your abilities mine
were honestly kind of limited I'm not
handy I'm not good with technology
anything with engineering is over my
head so I figured the simpler for me the
better I didn't want to rely on anybody
going in there for the first couple
months to just learn the basics this was
a business you could walk into and day
one more or less get it and so you uh
what happens you make them an offer you
meet them for lunch how do you how do
you actually get this deal done so for
me I stopped going anywhere until we
spoke about a tentative price range so I
would always throw out a number very
quickly cuz they were all kind of going
between three to four times so I'd think
okay if you're above the average
business I've looked at this month you
you're closer to four if you're below
that you're closer to three maybe closer
to two profits or Revenue Prof profits I
immediately got down to that on the
phone it was great you're in this range
they didn't really understand
terminology I wanted to keep it very
simple so I'd say okay what's your
income looking like what are you guys
averaging each year and they'd say the
numbers and so the I immediately was
thinking you know this is this is worth
three and a half times I always went a
little bit up because I always knew
there'd be more in the number to bring
it down but you want to be a little
optimistic but you're not ripping them
off you're not being dishonest you're
being in best case scenario it's
probably around here right so I threw
out a number and I go is your is your
price anywhere within that range because
a lot of people the combo ends because
they think they're business is worth 10x
and it's just not right so I give out
the number and he goes okay yeah I think
I can work somewhere within that range
he had looked into selling his business
previously so he was a lot more aware of
what these small businesses are actually
worth a lot of owners more realistic
about his baby versus saying this is the
best thing ever it's worth 20 times
profit right the second thing for me was
a sell's note that was a non-negotiable
for me that because a sell's note to me
was a substitute for getting equity and
I didn't want to get any investors
involved so the next step was okay are
you willing to do a sellers note and I I
phrased it a different way to make sure
he understood it but he actually did and
he was willing to do that and so then I
said okay let's talk now just to Define
num what what a seller's note is so
Define what is a sell's note for anybody
who doesn't know Absolutely I'll use an
example let's say you're buying a house
for a million dollars rather than giving
the seller a million dollars up front
this let's say you have a 25% sellers
note you would give that seller at close
$750,000 and then they would get paid
the remaining
$250,000 over time and whatever you
define those terms at whatever interest
rate you decide on and time Horizon yeah
the seller becomes the bank they're sort
of financing you to be able to purchase
the rest of the business exactly and it
was also great because the argument
there is because some sellers didn't
want to do it and the argument is well
you're telling me how great your
business is you're telling me that it's
simple enough for me to operate if those
things are true why would you have an
issue doing a seller's note right right
this thing stable right exactly and uh
my friend I helped my friend just buy a
business actually kind of similar to
yours uh recently and he did a good
thing which was in the sellers note he
said look here's the purchase price
here's the sellers note but if eida was
to drop way below where it is today
because you know I find some skeletons
in the closet or this thing turns out to
have been built on some quicksand then
we're going to forgive the rest of that
seller's note right and then he was able
to structure it accordingly so so it's
it's a good mechanism for for any buyer
um that's doing it I I I I don't did you
do that or did you just do a sellers
note as is I did it as is there's
something called an earnout which is
similar to what you're saying and it's
based on the performance of the business
and you choose am I going to do it on
revenue or profits for me I tried to
keep this extremely simple because the
devil really is in the details here and
these sellers a lot of them don't even
have high school degrees but they're
very good at business they've been very
successful so I'm trying to do a deal
here where these terms are extremely
straightforward and when you start doing
terms like that the seller freaks out
because then it's wait I may not get
this money I don't even know you all of
a sudden he skeptical of you so I'm not
a big fan of those yeah that that was
your other thing one one of your points
of view was like you know industry is
overrated I like that point why you know
because you're really looking for just
actually just this rare beautiful
business that's stable and profitable um
and you shouldn't like use industry
filters for that necessarily um have
have the thesis and walk in as this
genius who has a thesis up front H you
know be open-minded at at the start and
then the second part is you were like I
try not to use any jargon like no B even
though you were at business school you
weren't saying iida you would say how
much money are you making or income uh
you know you were not trying or even in
the structure you were not trying to get
super fancy in the structure
because if you don't understand it
they're not going to understand it
essentially right yes and that's the
biggest mistake too because people think
well I don't have a Harvard MBA or I
don't know any of this I honestly think
ignorance truly is bliss here because
the less you know it's kind of better CU
you can keep things extremely simple for
the seller and I think that breeds trust
and so you uh buy this business how much
cash did you put into the business to
buy it you don't need to put any cash
down and I didn't have to because of the
sellers note so I did a 25% sellers note
and a 75% bank note and the idea there
was when shopping around for a bank to
do the deal it was all about and it took
me you know 20 plus Banks to figure this
out it was all about how did they view
the sellers no banks that viewed that
sellers no which very few did as
Equity I could I could work with the
ones that didn't not so much because if
they viewed it as Equity it's like well
you're okay there's 25% Equity we'll
loan you the other
75% exactly exactly and how' you get
them to think that that was Equity
because it's not it's kind of not Equity
honestly I wish I could have some like
really Savvy answer here but it to be
frank and I'm not trying to to say this
about all banks but most Bankers have no
idea what they're doing or what they're
talking about truly I had to learn this
the hard way they think they can Finance
the deal they have no idea how to
finance the deal they have no idea what
these structures look what the details
are of these structures so a lot of it
I'm sorry it's just ignorance of them
and their board right said here's the
purchase price and then here's how much
we need from the bank and then they're
like oh rest is equity um and they
didn't call it Equity they knew it was
debt they called it
but the way they reviewed it like when
they're looking at their ratios for
these these Banks they have all these
rules it was whatever internal rules
they were using to evaluate the debt
ratio and and one big thing is this the
bank had priority over everyone else
right so the bank was going to be paid
before this sellers know and the
business had many many years of a track
record of profitability yes that's why
that that is so important you have to
have they're really banking on that
business's track record and then a
little bit with you it's a question of
okay it's done well for 20 years what
could you do to make it not do so well
right right and so you um you buy this
thing you told me you go the only asset
I had at the time I had no money no
experience no whatever I only owned my
my my car I had a Rav 4 and that's
literally like all I had to my name and
you were able to buy a multi-million
dollar business and then walk in and be
the owner of it just by really hustle
and a kind of a numbers game so we
didn't even talk about some of the
hustle of this so some of the hustle of
this was scraping the database some of
the hustle was getting people off
Craigslist to be interns to sift through
the database then it was well those
interns need a place to work so you got
fake IDs to get them into the library is
that right like tell the fake ID story
absolutely we hustled for those IDs too
we hustled for those that was hard work
you said you uh what was it you like
went to alumni you like you're like
looking at the intern and you're like
all right which Alum looks like this
intern and then I'll ask them for their
student ID hours of that truly hours we
shot to hundreds and hundreds of people
hundreds and so you've got these inter
then you realize hey we need to just be
blasting this kind of like fake it till
you make it email where it looks like
we've researched them specifically and
they'll sort of self- Select you end up
doing this deal where you don't put any
money down because you were able to shop
40 Banks or something like that to get
them to to give you the financing for it
a lot of this to me the story here is
like um not counting yourself out
because a lot of people Al somewhere
along that way would have counted
themselves out I don't know how to do
this you know uh this is uncertain I
don't have the money I don't have the
experience I don't have the time they
would find a way to count themselves out
you didn't do that uh figure out a way
to get it done so like you know don't
all the rules are sort of imaginary you
can you could sort of work around them
and the last one is it's just a numbers
game like you said it's like it's like
dating we're just going to need to look
at a lot of businesses we're going to
need to get a bunch of interns to find
the good ones we're going to look at a
bunch of businesses to find the good
ones we're going to talk to a bunch of
banks to find the one that will do this
deal is that accurate because that's
what I'm hearing yes if there are two
things I'm very passionate about in this
world it's obviously a currens but also
it's this concept of spreading the good
news which is that anyone who wants to
buy and I really mean anyone who wants
to buy and operate a small business can
do so it is not a matter of can or can't
it's a matter of will or won't that's a
fact because this is an industry where
you can choose any type of business you
want any size business you want you
could be a cleaner looking to buy
another really small cleaning business
from a guy or gal that's looking to
retire you can buy a dog Walking Company
there is truly No Limit here and that's
what I love about it because to me it's
one of the few areas left of the
American dream where you can go out and
just put in a ton of effort and elbow
grease and make something of your life
and actually make good money without
killing yourself and not having to work
you know three jobs right and so you
since you took over the business you
don't have to share the exact numbers
but let's just say if the business was
making $100 before um in the years since
you've bought the business what have you
been able to do like how have you grown
the B how much have you grown the
business and how what' you do to
actually grow the business because a guy
had been operating for whatever 15 16 17
years something like that you come in as
a beginner but you've been able to grow
the business so I want to know kind of
roughly like how much value were you
able to create how many multiples of
what you bought for and then also um
what did you do what what were the new
insights or techniques or or operational
things that you put in place to create
that value great questions here so when
I first bought the business the first
couple years things may have been on the
decline a little bit I may have made
quite a few mistakes and so it wasn't
looking too too promising you're not
getting invited on podcast for that
story at that time Sarah you bought a
business and you are driving it straight
into the ground how does it feel tell us
for what what's secret yeah I probably
would have been fired or kicked off as
CEO but what happened was so when I
first bought this business I'm just
going to back up really fast I really
thought I'm in the egg industry so I'm
looking what's the duck egg market like
what's the chicken egg Market you know
these things and realiz again Market's
kind of
BS it's all a bunch of crap these
Frameworks and stuff because you don't
really really know until you're in it
and I realized when I got in it I'm not
really in the egg industry I'm in
specialty packaging and so it actually
was a lot more of an opportunity than I
ever realized and I wasn't some genius
figuring this out I just looked at our
order history we were getting orders
from people that were selling crickets
and du buy roaches and people that were
using the egg cartons for um small parts
people that were using them for bath
bombs cupcakes I estimate now that 40%
of our Revenue has nothing to do with
eggs and so when I realized that there
was a lot of potential there and I
realized that our specialty was really
also these proprietary products I spent
most of my time focusing on that not
this really amazing modern website but
focusing on these products that I call
really sticky kind of a silly jargon
term year but these products were we're
making a custom mold for a customer that
they then are going to keep buying from
us assuming we don't rip them off or
totally botch it right and so from that
and then Co coid was like cheating
because we five Sixx during Co to answer
your question on the numbers we really
blew up so it was a combination of
recognizing how big our Market really
was and then recognizing that coid was
an incredible opportunity for us to take
all of our capabilities and run with it
right I like that and when you when you
talked about uh specialty packaging you
you said something to me you go in that
Google doc you go we're not we're not
about egg cartons anything that needs
sep what is it separation and prot what
did you call it separation and
protection prot I always say anything
requiring protection and separation is
fair game and I stand by that 100% it's
true anything and you think about how
massive that market is it's enormous
right yeah you could be making bras with
that definition I love it this is this
could be anything this is we're talking
cups we're talking what whatever you
want so you um truly and so are you like
reaching out by the way because like you
your website is still eggcartons.com and
I'm not trying to Sean Parker you like
drop the eggs just carton.com that's the
way to go here if you're making 40% off
of non-egg stuff why don't you kind of
Rebrand it so it's funny we are actually
in the process of doing a little bit of
that and I've continued to buy a bunch
of domain names so things like machine
shop trays or bath bomb
cartons any variations of that I'm just
buying domains left to right who knows
whether they'll stick but that's that's
a huge portion of it but it's very
challenging to figure out how to do that
without compromising other important
variables other important Revenue
drivers it's a lot more challenging than
you'd think but we are tierpoint looking
into that I'm always like stop with the
eggs and everyone of the companies like
we sell egg carts it's taken me years to
really get people to understand this is
bigger than eggs we're not abandoning
the Farms we're not abandoning the
chickens you guys it's just way bigger
than that so like stop talking about the
chickens and the Ducks and whatever the
geese I'm so jealous of you cuz I feel
like if I ran an egg carton company I
could fulfill my dream of being Michael
Scott at Thunder Mifflin and like just
come into the warehouse I just imagine
that this is like a Dunder Mifflin style
business and you could come in and like
you know um you know just have be the
crazy boss every day do you when you
look back now at what you did because
again we talked about starting as a
rookie if you could go back and I gave
you an hour that you could uh spend with
you know younger you either during the
search process or during the early days
of of the business what would what would
you if I could give you that time when
would you go back to what would you tell
yourself as advice um with the wisdom
and the the benefit of
hindsight so I would actually just
borrow the advice I got from my mentor
but I'd actually follow it which there
were two pieces it was higher and Fire
fast didn't do that huge mistake and do
not change anything big or really
anything at all the first year both of
those things cost me a
lot what about that that second one tell
me more about that so it's obviously a
Temptation you come in you're so excited
you've been searching you've been
searching You' searching you finally
find the thing you close the deal after
painful you know you don't know it will
it go through will go through it finally
closes and now the keys are yours it's
got to be tempting to go play with the
toys um what what's the what's the wrong
way to do that what's the right way to
do
that yeah so let's get into that
actually when I come in I'm thinking
okay I knew I didn't know much truly I
didn't think I was going to reorganize
the warehouse or start changing anything
seemingly big but there were things that
I thought were really simple like the
phones we had hardwired phones in our
office and there were cables everywhere
because we've got all these offices and
conference rooms I'm thinking dude this
is like 20 whatever like warm lless in
2020 here what are we doing with this we
should just change our phones to Vo phon
so that I can see everything remotely
where there's not phones ringing let's
get you know into the Modern Age here
seems like not a big thing no that was
one of the biggest mistakes I made
because you called and our phone number
is actually extremely important people
look at the Domain that's great but our
number is used by our biggest customers
by the the new customers it's everything
to us and we actually have multiple
phone numbers that that one800 number is
forwarded to like 10 12 lines and so
it's very important
and Spectrum may have lost our phone
lines mid porting and so our phones were
down for almost a week and it was a huge
deal because it was a new owner and
people are thinking did they go out of
business right what is going on here cuz
you're not the phones are gone they're
dead now and it was a huge so it's like
maybe just do a first off I wouldn't do
anything with the phone lines now I'm
I'm to this day I will not change our
phone lines because I've been so
traumatized by the experience but if if
you were maybe you just like change one
phone line maybe two maybe not all of
them but something like that that you
think is small can actually be pretty
big I like that and you you said like we
kind of hinted at this earlier but uh I
want to make this point which
is I've uh you know I said one thing you
didn't do is you didn't count yourself
out and that's important I think one of
the reasons people count themselves out
almost subconsciously is that they um
they don't see the themselves a certain
way they've never done that their family
didn't do this and so they just sort of
are like I don't know I guess that's
just something other people do and
that's even if you hear something you're
like that that sounds like a cool idea
but like where where would I start I
have no I have no foothold here to do
that and you have a pretty unique
background that I think should you know
debunk that idea of of of kind of like
even if you're not from that track you
can sort of get on that track at any
time and so uh when I first was talking
to you I was like wow this is some whip
smart you know Harvard per it's like
basically you take the Harvard pedigree
but then she added some some Street
Smart some hustle and I thought that's
what I thought when I met you and then
you were like you said something like
you're like I didn't even take the SATs
and I was like wait how'd you get into
Harvard Business School tell the story
of your background because I think it's
kind of
amazing okay yeah this is a little
detail here so we're going to go way
back um I'm one of three and my my
sisters and I would say sort of had a
subpar upbringing in that we didn't
really have parents and we were split up
and we bounced around and living in a
lot of different homes my two older
sisters they made the most of it they
got really into academics and sports I
made the worst of it I would say and I
became somebody that you would not want
your kids hanging out with okay I was
partying all the time I had a I would go
to school so I had a truancy officer I
went to jail I I was just so
disrespectful to everyone and I got away
with it because people felt sorry for me
and the beginning of high school I was
living with a woman that was an
alcoholic and her favorite thing when
she got drunk was to take all my items
and throw them out into the front lawn
and just tell me to leave and I didn't
really have anywhere to go I was a kid
and so there was a woman named Natalie
Bracken who used to pick me up and take
me to her house and she'd let me stay
there until this woman
inevitably you know came back to Earth
and said where did you go and called the
police and so it was constantly going
back and forth between Natalie's the
bracken's house and this other household
I was being transported by the police
and no one could really do anything
about it nobody seemed to really
care and one day just she just got so
fed up and she said I'm going to adopt
you obviously it was pretty
informational so I'm living in her home
with with her family and her daughter I
was actually friends with so her husband
one day kind of let me have it because I
was trying to skip school like the first
week living there and he sat me down and
he he literally explained and it sounds
it's embarrassing almost to say that he
literally explained how life worked to
me the basics of you don't lie you don't
just skip things when you don't want to
show up that's not how this isn't
reality and he explained where my life
was going which was basically absolutely
nowhere and it was very emotional for me
because up until that time a lot of
people had given me lectures but it felt
like it came from this place of you're
bothering me or this is really
inconveniencing me so can you just stop
your crap where he came from this place
I could tell he really cared and up
until then I didn't really feel like
anybody did
care and so I got my [__] together very
quickly after that I really did I
was so nervous about like being like
sent back or them regretting their
decision because up until that time no
one and I mean no one was looking to
invest in me I was like a junk bond
investment wise this is not a safe
investment I was not a good kid I didn't
do myself any favors and so after that
and getting my [__] together step one
was getting a job and so the first time
I ever remember studying truly in my
life was with Mrs Bracken when I was
learning a menu to get a job at a diner
and then from there I applied those new
study skills I had to school Mr Breet
had explained like listen you've got a
2.0 here kid you're not getting anywhere
but Community College with that so you
need to like G act together and so from
there I got all A's because I wanted to
boost my average at least to a
3.0 I'm working at this Diner and this
couple would come in all the time and
they never had kids and we just got not
along that's the best way to explain it
I never told them about my upbringing
really initially I think my co-workers
probably did there were days I probably
weren't there and they probably could
just tell and so they offered me a job
at their company probably initially out
of sympathy out of the kindness of their
heart and I started working there and it
just it just seemed to fit and so when I
was working there I got weight listed
from North Eastern where I ended up
going to college and when I was weight
listed did the owner of the so these two
I'm sorry backing up this couple I had
no idea they were extremely wealthy I
always thought rich people were at fancy
restaurants but this couple's coming in
going to a diner getting cheeseburgers
each week I had no idea like they're
worth a lot of money and when I was
weight listed Steve said you need to
take yourself off of financial aid
because of these schools especially a
school like nor Eastern without a big
endowment they're going to take that
into consideration when evaluating your
candidacy and I said how am I going to
take myself up eight I have no money and
this school is so expensive and he said
we're going to pay for your
school wow and so yeah I mean it's I
it's very it's hard for me to not an
emotional talking about because it's so
between these two couples I mean they
changed my entire life um they it wasn't
just the money too it wasn't just the
home it was these people changed the way
I viewed myself they invested me when I
was truly the world's worst investment I
mean who takes a kid like me what I was
like and say you know what I'm going to
go all in on this like they put their
ass out in the line for me on multiple
occasions with the worst track record
record you can possibly imagine like
truly possibly
imagine and from these two these two
families I had this whole concept in my
head of I just want to be that one
person for one person because for me I
literally begged when I was a kid
sometimes for people to help me I would
beg judges I would beg attorneys I would
beg social workers to like put me in
better circumstances or help me with X
and Y nobody helped me at all they felt
sorry for me but nobody took action so
this concept of being that one person
for one person carried over into college
because I went to North Eastern to be a
social worker initially and that was way
too kumbi off for me as you can probably
tell I'm not like that's just not me and
so from there I said okay something a
little bit more aggressive more me could
be law I was watching CSI what I thought
of law so I figur I'm going to be in
Juvenile Justice I I can be I I can be
the attorney I wanted to have I can be
the social worker I want to have but
again it was I just realized these
professions were just not me so one day
I called Steve the owner of this company
I worked for I call him boss and I said
hey boss like I don't know what I'm
going to do here I'm now a junior in
college and I've worked for you but
that's kind of my only work experience
and I have no I have no experience in
anything but criminal justice now and
social work and I don't want to do these
professions and he said you are not an
academic
you're you are Geared for business It
comes naturally to you and he said and
you can have a way bigger impact in
business than like criminal justice or
social
work and so I said okay well what am I
going to do now though because I'm in my
junior year and I don't have anything to
show for this I can't just go and get a
I can't just go into a business who's
going to want me and he said you need to
go to business school cuz he had gone I
didn't even know it he had gone to
Stanford Business School back in the day
they went right after school but now the
average age of business school
candidates at least at the Ivy Leagues
like Harvard is 28 and when we were
talking about this I was like 21 I was
about to graduate and um I
said there's no way I'm going to get
into a business school he didn't know I
had paid my sister to take my SAT from
me because I had confidence I can study
hard enough but I'm not going to get
caught up enough I don't even know
what's on the SAT I imagine it's all the
subjects but I just had no confidence in
myself like when I got to college I was
at a 33% reading level what does that
mean I I went off campus one day and
like I like it was horrible so I went
off campus one day because I was
convinced this is horrible I was really
convinced I was mentally handicapped
when I got to college because I just did
not understand anything and I got this
test done and they said there's really
nothing nothing wrong with you're just
like at a low level here and they did
say my intelligence was below average at
that time and so it was it was horrible
because it was a factual evidence hey
you're not that bright and by the way
you're you're at the 33 percentile like
oh that's [__] great like it it
basically put into P onto paper that I'm
an idiot and it was heartbreaking for me
but I was so embarrassed and I didn't
want anyone to know and so the only
thing I really knew at that point was to
just try really hard and again I didn't
want to disappoint like my biggest fear
to this day would be to disappoint the
brackens or the greens like ever and I
just I figure if they've gotten me here
I have to make this work and so I I
studied like you wouldn't believe like
nobody knows the nor Eastern University
Library like I do so I studied my ass
off and I my biggest fear was even
getting a be can I question about that
that part um I've met a couple people in
my life who have had that sort of like I
come to Jesus moment or that but but I
call it like the conversation with
yourself it's like there's a day where
you have a conversation with yourself
like look it's this is either going to
go one of two ways either this is what
it is and it'll just be what it's going
to be or like I'm going to change it I
and I always ask them because I I I
think these Mo there's a few moments in
your life where like decades are are
sort of decided and it's some
conversation you have with yourself this
is my theory I don't know you tell me
was there a conversation you had with
yourself at that time to be like okay
I'm just going to apply I'm going to go
in bury myself in this Library until I
come out with the 99% reading level or
what what happened
there I've never been one of those like
long-term planners it was for me it's
more of a day-by-day week by week thing
but I did have this mentality I remember
of I'm going to give this literally
everything that I have everything that I
have like every day I really mean that
because I will I had a mentality of I
will not disappoint these people I will
not disappoint them so if that means I
studied Round the Clock and it still
wasn't good enough at least I can say I
gave this literally everything and I'm
sorry that was kind of my thinking that
was it a lot of people think that it's
you know the hardest thing is when
nobody believes in you actually the most
pressure is when almost nobody believes
in you but a couple people do and when a
couple people do it adds a whole
different level of emotional pressure to
the situation more so than when nobody
believes in you yes it's funny I it's
rare to I don't never me actually
anybody that gets that but that's
exactly how I felt I wanted to live I
felt like what they believed in me
wasn't true and so I wanted to live up
to who they thought I was that who I
didn't think I was that's I mean I
didn't come from the situation you came
from I was luckier than that uh it just
to be born into the right sort of family
and circumstances but um yeah the the
Birch family here in San Francisco
they're the ones who were that for me
where you know I'm 24 years old and they
they invested in me and they they sat
they literally sat me down and said I
think you're going to do special things
they go we've met a lot of people in
Sila Valley I think you're going to do
special things you're going to go on to
do special things we want you to do them
you know we just think then they Nam me
CEO of the company they like here's the
keys we think you should do them here
you're going to do them at some point
and at that time I didn't really view
myself as special in any way um it was
kind of the first time that somebody had
ever really said something like that but
also put their money where their mouth
was that wasn't maybe my parent where my
parent it's like ah uh in a way you sort
of take that for granted unfortunately
and so I took that for granted when my
parents would say oh you're so great
it's like yeah just like every mom you
know thinks their kids so great you know
that's how I felt at the time um and
hearing a total Outsider you know this
billionaire say no no no I believe in
you and then and then for me soul
crushing the next six years I like
didn't succeed but I was trying really
hard but I wasn't succeeding and I
remember feeling that pressure of like
did I was I remember think like I wish
nobody believed in me that would be
easier um than somebody really believing
you and you not wanting to disappoint
them um that was I remember just feeling
that day by day so I I definitely at
least resonate with that part of your
story yeah no that's that's really
that's that's very real it's funny a lot
of people will say oh I didn't have it
as bad as you but it's all I learned a
lot of the same and you adapt to what
you're going through so I'm sure the
feelings in a lot of ways were actually
almost the same but the externals just
looked a little bit differently yeah
yeah your life is a movie um and my life
is uh you know like you know the the
normal thing but like your life is
literally I told you this on the phone
your life is literally the plot of the
movie blinds side like you're just not
this like huge football player instead
you you know you're you went and bought
a business instead but like same sort of
idea where people you know took a took a
chance on you have you uh taken that
mentality of like be one person what was
it be one person for one be that person
for one person um be that one person for
one person I love that that's kind of
amaz is that from something or did you
invent that it just I kept it just came
to me I don't know I it was just
something I thought of one day have you
done that do you feel like you've been
able to do that do I feel like I've been
able to do that that I do actually and
that's truly one of the most rewarding
things about my job now and why I try
and keep my circle very small I'm really
big on doing what these families did for
me as much as possible which is a lot of
one-on-one mentorship because I can only
do so much on a mass scale but one onone
I can
really bring people to the next level
what ever that level is and I'm huge on
and I have no tolerance for people's
self-doubting I'll say nope you can do
it like do it again we're doing this
again and I will sit there and everyone
of the business I used to say I will
come any day any time I will sit with
you for as long as it takes if you try
and you're honest with me I'm not going
to give up on you and I I really mean
that if somebody tries and they're
honest with me I'm not giving up on them
right when you were talking I was
getting Goosebumps uh on my arm here
because I I mean I love love the story
but also um I think that coming on a
podcast like this and telling your story
is going to do that for someone
somewhere that you don't even know it's
a different way of doing it but like
somebody out there is going to hear this
or they're going to forward it to
somebody who said and say listen I don't
even know if you know what the podcast
app is but you need to hear this because
you know something in there is going to
resonate with somebody and so uh that's
why I was getting Goosebumps because
there's a way to kind of like the egg
carton story and buying a business is
cool that was kind of the bait uh but
the the real kind of like the real story
here is is kind of just the the
mentality and also um uh those families
that did that for you you know I think
that's uh it's not as flashy as you know
creating a foundation and giving away a
billion dollars or whatever but it is it
is a version of like you know
philanthropy or or sort of giving back
or cont contributing that is uh you know
can change change somebody's life in a
in a huge way versus a lot of people's
life lives in a small way right and I
think that's what's way more important
to me and seeing it helps me a lot it
keeps me motivated cuz unfortunately the
farther removed you get from it the
harder it is to remember what did you
have to do when you kind of rewired
yourself like what was the uh when you
did try to that's a big shift right you
basically changed all your habits maybe
not overnight but like you changed all
the [__] you were doing that was getting
you the bad results into things that
started to get you good results um
was it like what what was what was that
like how did you do
that I wish it was deep and I had like
steps for you but it was a it was a lot
of fear I was really scared of being
anything like what I was I was scared of
what I would be in the future it's kind
of like a drug addict that nearly dies
from an overdose and they are just
scared straight I was kind of scared
straight and so I also honestly lost
interest in a lot of things I used to be
interested in I used to get into fights
I used to gossip I used to there was
this golf course I used to get drunk
pass out on the golf course wake up to
the sprinklers no joke and I was
disgusted by it afterwards thinking
about it like who is that I don't even
want to be around that it was like the
idea of the taste or the smell bothering
somebody it was like that but from there
it was hard because I didn't know I
didn't have any of the tools like I
never I did not read a single book in
high school not one book right you
um I have a couple of docs here I want
to share one is uh because I think it's
cool to see the actual screenshots you
you shared with me because uh the funny
thing is when you told the story The
when when we told the story the first
time on the podcast there was two
reactions one is wow that's an
incredible story because here's what I
tweeted out so I said I have a new hero
and and her name is Sarah Moore at under
30 years old she had no money no
experience and the biggest asset was her
car a RAF 4 she spent one year hunting
through like 100,000 businesses to find
one to buy and she bought a I guessed at
the time but I didn't know if this was
true she bought a you multi-million
dollar business called eggcartons.com
with all debt no no cash down and so I
told that story and I told on the
podcast and basically the two reactions
were wow that's incredible so awesome
you know you go girl and on the other
side it was um calling [__] no way
and people were like that's that's not
you know you can't buy it all debt
nobody could sift through 100,000
businesses um How do you go to Harvard
and not have anything not have any money
and honestly I started to when I saw
those tweets I was like damn that never
occurred to me actually like yeah you're
right she was saying she kind of came
from nothing and blah blah blah but
she's at Harvard Business School like
and I was like am I getting [__]
daros right now is this Elizabeth Holmes
and I'm just getting duped um and so so
that happened and then we have this
researcher the
researcher uh you you text us the other
day you were like hey somebody's like
contacting a bunch of my old interns and
it was like our researcher fact checking
just to make sure we don't look like
idiots that like we're putting somebody
on who did this actually happen um but I
think that's kind of a cool thing that
your story was literally too good to be
true that people just started calling
[__] and I remember you didn't have
any social media so there was no way for
you to explain or tell your side the
story and then I think your sister like
created a Twitter account or something
it started like that day she was like
tweeting like no I'm in the car with her
right now yeah we grew up broke and like
we didn't have a family and like all
this stuff and I was like wow I don't
know what's happening right now but this
is fascinating do you remember that that
is so yes it started blowing up on
Twitter and everyone my company was
talking about it and my interns were
talking about and they're like Sarah you
need to go out there and defend yourself
like we're going to defend you and I was
worried about I know the internet can be
vicious and I was worried about anybody
getting any of that like you know
pointed at them and then I started
worrying about my company so my sister
got on there and she was we're very
protective of each other she was she
created a Twitter just to go on there
and defend me is this the SAT sister or
the other sister this is the SAT this is
the bright well they're both
exceptionally bright but she's actually
the director of HR for ABAC cromi and
Fitch like corporate level so she goes
so we're uh husband now but fiance the
time goes you need to delete this Jane
like you're something to lose yeah it's
a lose situation like you guys are
idiots why are you trying to defend
yourself amongst like people online
we're like it's getting out of hand so
we had no I just that was my concern
that people were going to think this was
fake and this was somehow going to
snowball in a negative Direction and all
I cared about was preserve the business
like don't [__] with a cart.com don't
let this random dude on the internet
blow this whole blow your spot up all
right so then you shared with us a bunch
of the things so you shared with us the
Craigs we'll put this on on YouTube so
people can actually see the the
Craigslist post but you wrote um Kenston
green what's Kenston green that's what
you named your thing I Mentor
recommended to make the name of the
company a name that would have a story
to it and so I deliberately said I
wanted to say I'm from Cleveland and I
worked in the steel business I want to
say I'm a bluecollar gal like you and so
Kenston was the name of my high school
in Cleveland I'd say and green was the
name of the family IID worked for in the
steel industry right so when they would
ask immediately what's I don't no one
wants an intro right hey I'm they don't
care but when they'd say what's Kenston
green it was my way of giving an intro
without giving an intro that's amazing
also it sounds kind of powerful and old
money
sounding I didn't mean for that but yeah
no it works uh so you wrote It's a small
unorthodox private Equity Firm accurate
unorthodox for sure very unod probably
very
private just
me um he said unlike a traditional
private Equity Firm we will acquire just
one business and the principal will
operate upon acquisition all right no
lies are told and said you will be
working for an eccentric unpretentious
Harvard MBA all right I like it and
exposed to live deals interactions with
Brokers accountants and attorneys and
due diligence and negoti negotiations of
various sorts every day see that's
awesome you're you're saying like the
value you're going to get out of this
unique experience um we're looking for
interns to help manage our multi-stage
high volume funnel high in all caps um
in the most efficient way possible it
includes blah blah blah blah blah and
you said you know I like this work will
not include Financial modeling
sophisticated analyses or anything that
you or anyone else thinks is a waste of
time tell me about that because that is
beautiful love that in a in a job post I
hate wasting people's time one of my
biggest pet peeves are these jobs people
have to sit there until 5 6 whatever
o'clock and rub their fingers to leave
it's like when your work is done just
leave and don't pretend to be busy don't
pretend like you're not on your cell
phone so I'm not going to ask them do to
do anything that's not going to be
important very important right and
they're not doing some this isn't
Harvard we're not going to be doing
these
crazy Financial analyses it's really
simple it can be done on the back of a
piece of paper yeah cuz most of the time
when you call these businesses you're
like so what's your profit for the year
and they're like I think it's like
1.4 no let me 1.6 I don't have my
numbers in front of me and they're like
and you look it's like actually you made
900k last year and they're like yeah I
don't know what I gotta ask my guy about
that um it's not like you're doing you
know the diligence it's like they don't
know their business it's not like
they're hiding something from you they
don't know it themselves this so so
common um all right so then you said a
bunch of other things looking for
somebody hungry hungry comfortable with
chaos um then here's compensation
because some people were also like oh
unpaid interns that's crazy and it's
like dude I don't have any money and
like this is these are willing and able
people choosing to do this because they
see some value in it for them you said
this is an unpaid internship if you're
looking for a glamorous internship in a
formal prestigious work environment this
job is not for you we are operating out
of an unassuming spot in a library I
will provide letters of recommendations
as well as introductions to anyone in
consulting firms Banks or private Equity
firms should you perform well um should
you perform well good good qualifier I
will also help you with recruiting
interviewing and grad school prep if you
want me
to wonderful this is wonderful this is
so good I love seeing this um I also
have here an email you sent um I think
you were maybe sending this to a broker
um but just very clear and direct to the
point you were like hey my name is SAR
Moore I'm a recent business school grad
living in Boston I want to buy a small
business that meets this criteria 100%
of the business is for sale the iida or
seller seller earnings are 1 to two
million it's been profitable the last
three years and seller financing is
available um I have preference of B I
have a preference for B2B service but
this is not a requirement I'm able to
finance acis below 25 million please let
me know if you have any listings like
very direct clear and were things like
like how did you increase your luck so
like how did you put things out there to
increase the amount of good things that
would come inbound to you
let's go there actually I I have
something for you guys I put to the side
here okay so people talk all the time
about this industry and being a woman
and they think that it's a disadvantage
well that's matter of perspective I
deliberately wanted to leverage my
gender and so part of that was within
the broker Community it's all men
usually so I'm 5'9 and I would go to
only free broker events but I would go
to them in 5in heels so I'm walking
around as this 6'2 Amazon and always
wear like a ridiculous outfit too like a
loud color so when I'd call the Brokers
I'd say cuz they never remembered they'd
say who are you again I'd say I'm that
extremely tall chick that introduced
myself to you looking for a business
there wasn't a single person that didn't
remember that's for the Brokers but then
I'm very active so I'd be going around
Boston on these blue bikes which are
free of course and I would be running or
doing whatever and I wore this
sweatshirt a version of this too like
every day I want to buy your business
and then the back was my number I it was
an interesting experience with this yeah
everywhere anything to get yourself it
was anything free where I can I wanted
the world to know I am looking to buy a
business and I'm
serious did you um get any good inbound
from this was that like did somebody
call you being like hey I just saw you
ride by me on a bike um I think I caught
this number correct I'd like to sell you
my business it's funny I I didn't think
it was working but you'd be amazed at
what comes out of the woodwork um
there's actually somebody that came over
and said you know what my my dad asked
me about whether or not this was
actually a legitimate business like are
you actually looking to buy something
and that worked out and then I faxed
everybody that was one of the interns
idea to send out Mass faxes and part of
the faxing campaign was just putting
anything that will get their attention
so part of it I did put my picture on
there and I'd say we want to buy your
business and I I told you this to this
day I I have people that recognize me
from those faxes people in the mill that
I work in said wait a second I was
wondering why you look so familiar did
you try and buy my business like people
on my street to this day in downtown
Boston will say you're that girl that
was wearing that sweatshirt or you're
that girl that was faxing me all the
time that's what I wanted unfortunately
I I I a lot of those um replies came
back after I bought a business but I was
just that was what I was really hoping
for somebody see it and know I was
serious well that's brilliant because
you're looking for these kind of uh
long-standing sort of boring B2B service
businesses they have fax machines
nothing interesting is coming through
the fax machine so it's a completely
untapped unsaturated Channel you're like
and I'm going to turn my disadvantages
into advantages okay people say the
disadvantage to be a woman you're not
going to be taken seriously blah blah
blah you're not going to be included in
whatever well I'm also going to stand
out if I'm the minority right like I'm
going to be different than everybody
else and I'm going to use the sort of
psychology to my favor here and I love
that you did that and are not like shy
about that because I think a lot of
people are very shy about things like
this and um I love that you did that you
faxing a picture is to me like it's in
the all time hustle moves and I'll also
say it doesn't matter if some of this
stuff works
because one life motto do it for the
story I think that's that's a that's
already just like a winning thing to do
is just do things for the story and two
is there's something that comes with the
mentality of nothing is off limits I
will do anything I am all [__] in and
it's a signal to yourself it's a signal
to your interns and your team it's a
signal to everybody in the world that I
am all [__] in and no idea is off
limits no idea is too dumb no idea is
too too out there too too um you know
too loud no no we are everything's on
the table as as a thing that we might do
and I think that is the value of some of
these things whether it's the lead that
actually brings in the business or not
is kind of secondary and I love that you
did that anything Sean truly I was
Shameless if I had anything I could
throw out there I was throwing it out
there whatever stuck I was okay with hey
I'm Sarah Sarah Moore 5 foot n brunette
if that's your thing I would love to buy
your Pest Control
business truly whatever it takes and if
I could find out maybe the profits of
your business I'd be happy to join you
for a coffee uh let's let's do this um
that's so so funny yeah and if you could
leave uh any listeners to this with one
I don't know message or takeaway what's
what's your kind of what's your message
what's
your what's the last thing you want to
sort of leave in people's minds here so
my biggest value is freedom this country
was not founded on equality despite how
things seem now with the culture it was
founded on freedom and part of freedom
is using everything at your disposal so
gender sex age whatever makes you you
you can use any of those things to
literally pull yourself up by your
bootstraps and make your life what you
want it this industry I can promise you
is one of those Industries you don't
have to have Harvard MBA what made me
successful at this I really think was
largely my upbringing those things
weren't taught to me at Harvard to get a
business the things I do day-to-day were
not taught to me at Harvard they were
taught at the cliche School of Hard Knox
so if you want to be free
pursue this route freedom is not free
it's going to cost you time it's going
to cost you like a lot of effort but I
can promise you that anyone that wants
to do this can do this if they really
put their all into it and normally I say
at the end uh how should people follow
you or reach you but you don't really
have social media and I think we may not
want people to be reaching you after
this um so like what's your message is
leave me the [__] alone is it stay
away do you want to be contacted from
this what what would you like my biggest
thing I I've said what I want is for
anyone who wants to pursue this career
path I want everyone to have a fair
opportunity to do so which is why I'm
talking about it I'm going to give
people within a Q&A type format detailed
information to answer all the questions
I get but we have truly experienced this
crazy amount of volume on my in my inbox
on my LinkedIn of messages like
thousands and it really breaks my heart
not being able to get back to all of
them so I'm doing a mass reply that's
that's the idea here we're going to give
you as much information as we possibly
can but please understand that I cannot
respond to all these inquiries like I
have a full-time job like I own other
companies too we're very busy so the
biggest thing is please do not contact
our business please do not show up at
the business we're going to create a
Google doc something for you guys to
fill out if you want information we'll
send it to you but I I just can't get
back to everybody like I'm not used to
this I went I'm like a nobody so I'm not
used to all this attention all these in
Mount inquiries I can't I can't respond
to them all I'd love to I really would
but I can't so we're going to put a form
in the description here that'll be like
people can fill that in you'll send them
a blast and amazing if there are people
who fill out that form uh I might cherry
pick a couple of people and be like hey
if you're serious about this like I'll
help you do it like I I don't I'm I'm
taking a break from running companies uh
you know we sold our last company last
year I don't want to start a new company
right now but I do want to do fun fun
projects and one of the fun things is
helping people buy business businesses
that's one of the things that is
actually pretty pretty dope because you
learn about all these Niche businesses
you get like the free
MBA right yeah so so I think it's a good
time you learn so much searching when I
hear about people failing at this it's
like you really can't fail unless you
get investors of course but you really
can't I I mean the amount we still laugh
at some of the businesses out there and
you view the world differently you view
like I think of the freeway now and the
the lines on the freeway and the signs
on the freeway somebody made all of that
right like these Christians come in like
wow God made this and I'm thinking that
and all these businesses made like all
this stuff that we're looking at in
using it's kind of wild right you're
like no that's Trent in Cincinnati he
does that what do you
mean he has a
name all right uh Sarah thanks so much
for coming on I really appreciate it and
uh really inspired by your story so
thank you for coming and telling it
thank you for having me I appreciate
it
[Music]